Oh
in one of my previous videos we looked
at the possibility of terraforming Mars
into a kind of backup earth to avoid
extinction events such as asteroid
impacts and while it is very possible
that we'll see colonies on Mars within
our lifetime it raises the question why
don't we ever hear about colonizing
Venus by all accounts it looks more
promising on paper venus is closer to
Earth than Mars is it's nearly identical
in size to Earth has a gravity very
similar to Earth and it has a nice thick
atmosphere to protect the surface from
harmful radiation sounds perfect right
well our sister planet has a few flaws
that make her a bit less agreeable to
human life to put it simply if you are
asked to picture a blood-soaked
nightmarish hellscape you could very
easily picture the surface of Venus say
you were part of a daring mission to
land on the surface of Venus and you
managed to touchdown somewhere without
dying
spoiler alert that's impossible but just
go with it you hop out of your land are
ready to proudly plant your flag then
you burst into flames
then you implode then your lander
implodes then your lucky block of lead
melts get the picture the surface of
Venus is really really hot around 450
degrees Celsius at the equator the
pressure on the surface is unbearable
even for reinforced probes at roughly 90
times greater than on earth this has
caused the untimely demise of various
probes over the years with even the most
successful missions being extremely
short-lived lasting around an hour at
most
okay so surface landings are out of the
question for now doesn't that rule Venus
out for colonization not entirely we
just have to think a little more star
wars it's true that the surface of Venus
is far too hot but as you ascend through
the atmosphere the temperature begins to
drop dramatically at an altitude of
about 50 kilometers it measures a much
more manageable 75 degrees Celsius
Jeffrey Landis of NASA's Glenn Research
Center explains that a problem with the
Venus colony stems from our preconceived
notions of what colonization looks like
he says the problem with Venus is merely
that the ground level is too far below
the one atmosphere level at cloudtop
level
venus is the paradise planet and he's
not exaggerating well maybe a little bit
but the fact is that the upper
atmosphere of Venus looks very promising
indeed as early as 1971 scientists began
to propose various approaches to
colonizing the Venusian atmosphere more
recently we've seen proposals of what
are called aerostat
that's basically more advanced blimps or
rigid airships followed by something
straight out of a sci-fi movie floating
cities let's start by looking at the
prototype habitats
since the Venusian atmosphere is mostly
composed of dense carbon dioxide a
mixture of breathable air composed of
oxygen and nitrogen could act as a
lifting gas equivalent to about 60
percent of the lifting power of helium
here on earth the idea is that a large
balloon full of human safe gases could
suspend a small colony or scientific
outpost in midair the balloon would be
safe from the searing heat and
overwhelming pressure of the surface and
would be shielded from cosmic radiation
by the upper atmosphere which has a
roughly equivalent shielding potential
to earth the little floating outpost
could drift along indefinitely gathering
useful information about our sister
planet well it wouldn't exactly drift
along as wind speeds above the cloud
layer can reach up to 340 km/h but still
there would be no harm in letting the
balloon be carried around the planet on
the winds in fact allowing the blimp to
move freely rather than attempting to
keep it in one place would greatly
reduce structural stress from the wind
when we think about the kind of
protective gear astronauts typically
need to wear you probably picture the
big puffy white suit right the amazing
thing about the skies of Venus is that
colonists wouldn't need any of that
heavy pressurised equipment all they
would need is a source of oxygen and
protection from the occasional acidic
rain and higher temperatures as advances
are made to these floating colonies even
the need for these small protective
measures could be done away with
we could see an enclosed dome full of
breathable air rendering oxygen tanks
unnecessary and allowing scientists to
work in relative comfort eventually we
could see full-scale floating cities
above the clouds of Venus
since the atmosphere is mostly carbon
dioxide it would be relatively easy to
grow plants and food after filtering out
the sulfuric acid this would go a long
way towards making colonies more
self-sufficient of course it's not all
sunshine and daisies above the clouds
there would still be some difficult
problems to overcome first venus is
almost entirely devoid of water in any
form those nice puffy clouds that would
be the highly corrosive sulfuric acid
and sulfur dioxide vapor speaking of
sulfuric acid it would be absolutely
critical that any craft in the Venusian
atmosphere be constructed of or coated
in material resistant to corrosion by
the acid now there is some water content
in the sulfuric acid itself but it would
have to be heavily treated and filtered
to be made safe for human use
importing water from earth or nearby
asteroids would be expensive and
time-consuming but seems to be necessary
based on our current understanding of
Venus of course even if we can solve
these problems efficiently and set up
thriving cloud cities there will still
be that nagging feeling pushing us to
really make the planet habitable such a
goal would require extensive
terraforming and with our current level
of technology that would take a very
long time
proposals for terraforming Venus cite
three main goals first remove or convert
the dense carbon dioxide atmosphere into
something more hospitable second reduce
the scorching 450 degrees surface
temperature and finally establish a
day/night cycle more similar to that of
Earth though some studies suggest that
Venus is 243 day rotation period would
actually be an advantage in preserving
earth-like conditions on a terraformed
Venus most proposals intend to reach
their goals by freezing most of the
planet's carbon dioxide and introducing
large amounts of hydrogen or water both
of which mean is desperately needs to
become more human-friendly
but these plans are a long way off
especially given the public's unending
interest in terraforming Mars so for the
time being we'll have to be content to
wait for our cloud cities then maybe
someday once we've established thriving
colonies above the Venusian clouds we
can brave the elements of the surface
and truly start to make Venus our home
away from home if you'd like to learn
more about Venus and its potential for
hosting life check out the links in the
description make sure to subscribe if
you haven't already and leave a comment
down below with what you think of the
idea of cloud cities if you enjoyed this
video be sure to check out my other
space related videos by clicking here or
if you've got some time to kill you can
watch all of my videos by clicking here
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video